Avenue 5 is a luxury passenger spaceship
which is on course for an eight-week
tour around Mars and Saturn owned by an
eccentric billionaire Hermann Judd the
spaceship is currently occupied by more
than 5 000 Rich passengers all of whom
want a glimpse of the solar system the
space crew of Avenue 5 is believed to be
the best in the world and it is led by
the experienced American captain Ryan
Clark Avenue 5 also has an impenetrable
shield which protects the passengers
from harmful radiation and has an
abundant supply of oxygen which can last
for up to three years however one day
because of a stupid error the fate of
the 5000 passengers hangs by a thread
the owner Judd who is known for being
childish wants to set a record by having
the largest yoga class in space so he
asks nearly a thousand passengers to
come to the ship's port and perform yoga
this overloads the port area and the
ship starts malfunctioning there's a
warning sign in the control room but
when an engineer Billy ignores it the
ship experiences something called a
gravity flip I thought Tony Hawk
invented that because of this all the
passengers are thrown from their feet
and launched at one side of the
spaceship chaos ensues as many of them
are seriously injured by the falling
debris this goes on for minutes but the
engineer from earlier Billy finally
manages to bring the situation under
control by pulling a lever at last the
ship regains its gravity but another
engineer named Joe who is repairing
something outside gets killed in the
aftermath Captain Clark makes an
announcement and tells everyone to be
calm he also promises that the shake was
only a minor inconvenience and that the
situation is under control however
little did he realize what was about to
be fall him and the Avenue 5. after the
announcement Clark keeps trying to
contact the engineer Joe oblivious to
the fact that he's already dead just
then Billy approaches him and reveals
some shocking news at first she mentions
that the spaceship is going to
experience a knock-on effect due to the
5 000 people smashing into one side of
the ship then she reveals that the
engineer Joe died as a result of the
gravity flip hearing this Clark has
taken aback and he leaves the scene in
anger on Earth at the Judd Galaxy
headquarters the control room watches
everything unfold in horror the mission
Chief RAV muclair conducts a scan of the
spaceship and gets devastating news
because of the knock-on effect the
Avenue 5 has missed its trajectory and
going back is not an option this means
that its previous eight-week Journey has
now been extended into a three-year one
RAV calls Judd his assistant Iris and
the others to the meeting room and
reveals the news which obviously
shatters them In the Heat of the Moment
Captain Clark starts blabbering in a
British accent
what the hell just happened with your
voice everyone is shocked to hear this
as they had assumed he was American this
is when Clark finally comes clean he
reveals that he is just a British actor
who was hired to motivate the crew and
the passengers With His Brilliant
speeches this means that he has no idea
on how to operate a spaceship and all
the stories about his gallantry in space
were lies
hearing this Judd and the others are
Furious and they inquire about who the
real Captain is with a soft voice Clark
responds that it was Joe the engineer
who died recently Joe is also the person
who hired him because he apparently had
weak social skills in the next scene
Clark who is still a decorated hero for
the passengers along with the engineer
Billy make an announcement in front of
everyone they reveal that the Avenue 5
is skidded off course and now it may
take around three years for them to
return home nonetheless Captain Clark
assures them that the engineers are
working day and night to secure a safe
passage and that they are completely out
of danger a nosy passenger Karen demands
more answers and Clark promises to
explain everything in detail but only
after they give engineer Joe a proper
send-off since the spaceship didn't
expect any disasters the authorities
didn't load it with any coffins but
surprisingly the egoistic Judd has
brought one along with him which is made
up of solid gold his assistant Iris
requests he donated for Joe's funeral to
which he reluctantly agrees later as
Clark is pretending to guide the ship in
the control room an engineer in shorts
named Cyrus arrives with a tablet and
reveals that he has found a shorter
route to Earth according to his
calculations they may return home in
just six months elated Clark shares the
news with Judd and the latter
immediately orders him to reveal this
information to the passengers but Billy
is against this she suggests that they
give the calculation a few tests as
Cyrus is known for exaggerating things
unfortunately Clark has already
disclosed the information to the
Chatterbox Karen who in turn has told it
to everyone oh Karen later during
engineer Joe's funeral ceremony Billy
approaches Clark and warns him that the
coffin is too heavy and might cause
problems but he shrugs her off after a
while the coffin is launched into space
but due to its sheer weight it starts
rotating the spaceship's orbit now
engineer Joe's coffin will be
accompanying them everywhere they go
elsewhere on Earth the mission Chief RAV
is holding a meeting with NASA to
convince them for a rest
shortly after RAV calls Judd and asks
him to explain the terrifying situation
on board the Avenue 5. the plan is to
gain sympathy from NASA and start the
rescue mission as soon as possible
unfortunately the Arrogant Judd asserts
that his team has already found a
solution with the help of which they
will return in just six months he then
swears at Nasa and tells them to Frick
off before ending the transmission the
same day things go from bad to worse
three passengers who were severely
injured during the knockoff disaster
from earlier pass away this time Billy
designs the coffins herself and makes
them extra light and transparent so that
they don't orbit the spaceship the
funeral ceremony goes as usual but just
as they are about to launch the coffins
RAV momentarily lowers the gravitational
pull inside the spaceship this doesn't
send the passengers crashing like before
but nonetheless they float in the air
for a while as for the coffins they
don't get enough power for the launch
and gets sent outside slowly now they
also orbit Avenue 9 along with Joe's
gold coffin the only difference is that
since these three coffins are
transparent the corpses are clearly
visible the following day Clark heads to
the dining room where he notices Karen's
influence increasing among the
passengers he also notices that the
current head of customer relations Matt
Spencer is only adding fuel to the
existing problems hence he decides to
invite Karen to his office for a meeting
that will benefit them both later the
two chat about the current affairs over
a glass of wine Karen's love wine
unfortunately even this time Clark gets
carried away and starts speaking in a
British accent tickle my ring piece that
is absolutely ex when his cover is blown
he eventually comes clean and reveals
that he is not a captain and as expected
this enrages Karen and she threatens to
inform all the passengers about it but
Clark calms her down and offers her the
role of the senior liaison officer her
role will be to chat with clients and
convince them that they are totally safe
and will return home in no time Karen is
still skeptical but Clark ultimately
changes her mind by giving her his
presidential suite after a while as
Clark is walking through the hallway the
engineer from earlier Cyrus approaches
him with some bad news he reveals that
he miscalculated the weight of the
spaceship the last time so his
Assumption of six-month return was wrong
now the original return back time is a
six-month addition to the existing three
years that was predicted earlier this
means that it will take three and a half
years for Avenue 5 to return to Earth
however there is one way to reduce the
weight and hence the duration if they
are somehow able to chuck around 500
passengers into space then they could
orbit faster but as expected Clark
immediately rejects the idea and walks
away later he meets the new liaison
officer Karen and briefs her about the
situation he then orders her to announce
this to the crew in the calmest way
possible so that they don't cause a riot
Karen obliges and comes up with an
emotional story which makes the crowd
erupt into Applause even after she
reveals that they will return home in
three and a half years
meanwhile Clark decides to take matters
into his own hands he heads to the
spaceship control room and asks the
engineers for new updates but
surprisingly all of them repeat the same
answers as if they have it memorized
this is when Cyrus arrives and reveals
that all the engineers here are actually
paid actors too they were hired by Judd
to impress the passengers with their
good locks hearing all this Clark
becomes Furious and starts screaming in
British again
hence blowing his cover in front of all
the actors after he's done with his
Outburst Billy removes the carpet and
opens a small door that leads to a
cramped up basement there several people
are seen working with computers Billy
reveals that they are actually the real
Engineers of the spaceship she and Cyrus
are also a part of their team and have
been working under the radar since the
first day the Revelation plunges Clark
into an even further abyss of confusion
and he starts wondering if there's
anything real in Avenue 5. in the next
scene he heads to the basement and
socializes with the guys over a couple
of beers to his surprise they seem to be
chill people who are still smiling and
happy despite the Grim situation they
are in such as the power of beer later
Judd organizes a party in his suite to
lighten up the mood Karen Clark and Iris
also join him in the four-star
brainstorming ideas to come up with a PR
strategy they want to let the people
back on Earth know that they are safe
and are living a comfortable life Clark
and Iris come up with intellectual plans
but Judd being Judd rejects every one of
them and proposes that they take a
picture with the kid near the wetsuit
compartment this compartment has the
best view to space and it is also the
shield that protects the spaceship from
harmful radiation what are the
components of the shield well it is just
human excrement wasting no time hundreds
of passengers mostly kids head to the
area for the perfect picture to make the
scene even more believable Judd requests
someone come up and press a random
button Karen's wife Frank volunteers and
does the job unfortunately at the exact
same time they pass through a random
star whose gravitational pull ruptures
the turd Shield this causes the human
excrement to come out at an alarming
rate now if it is not stopped urgently
the oxygen level will deplete and kill
everyone since the passengers still
regard Captain Clark as a hero they
encourage him to get out and fix the
problem left with no option he
reluctantly agrees with this the
engineers fit him into a spacesuit gear
him up with a calm and send him out of
the spaceship as the passengers inside
Avenue 5 and the rest of the world watch
closely Clark keeps floating irregularly
because he of course has no expertise in
this area none nonetheless with the help
of some instructions from the engineers
he reaches the spot where the turd
Shield has ruptured now all he has to do
is rotate the lever and stop the
Overflow but the task is not an easy one
as the lever is jammed shut and the
force in which the excrement is coming
out is exerting a lot of pressure
fortunately Billy also arrives there and
the two together manage to close the
lever hence stopping the Overflow the
whole world erupts into cheers and
Captain Clark becomes an overnight
sensation much to the annoyance of Billy
who is also equally helpful in this way
the catastrophe is averted but the human
excrement which was launched into space
now has started orbiting the spaceship
as well that evening Avenue 5 was
supposed to host a Midway home party
which would commemorate the end of their
fourth week in space however since
they're staying for the next three and a
half years and the resources for the
party are already booked they decide to
have a 1 45th of the way home party a
stand-up comedian named Jordan is
brought on stage to lighten up the mood
but all his jokes are either lame or the
crowd interrupts him Karen's husband
Frank who is amongst the crowd is
receiving threats from his fellow
passengers as they believed that him
pressing the button caused the entire
poop incident they demand he'd be thrown
out of the spaceship and Judd in a
drunken State also starts supporting
them soon some security officers arrive
and forcefully take Frank away it
appears as if they are really going to
throw him out of the spaceship Karen
desperately tells Judd not to do it but
he doesn't listen fortunately before
Frank can be terminated Clark who is now
a very respected man gets on stage and
urges the crowd to remain calm he then
makes them understand that it was not
Frank who caused the incident but the
gravitational pull of a nearby Star
saying this he urges Judd to bring Frank
back and the latter agrees soon Frank is
released from custody but instead of
thanking Clark he punches him straight
in the jaw it turns out that he has
started suspecting the captain of
sleeping with his wife as they are
always together meanwhile on Earth RAV
watches footage of the party and becomes
hopeful that the people will make it out
alive the episode ends as she heads to
meet the president of the United States
for help to see what happens next watch
the second part in series recapped